so you came from an authoritarian
government you were not allowed to say
you know I'm a free thinker in a
secularist
you've laid out why you can't you know
lived under an authority rule and now we
see this happening here and I'm firmly I
firmly believe that we are in like some
really murky waters in America right now
and in the West in general so what do we
do to fight this well I mean I mean
there is I think a domestic because now
is is coming to our lands here and it's
happening over there and when it comes
to what's happening over there I mean I
think the best solution for is to
support the values that I think there
are to be on the right side of history
on this battle between authoritarianism
and I would include theocratic fascism
in the in the umbrella and and the
values of John Stuart Mill and Jefferson
and the values of of the free man and do
you think do you guys think that those
are values of the left anymore when you
think of John Stuart Mill or classically
it seems to me that that's not even a
value that really I mean the list has
shifted and the right has shifted like
now we live in a I mean you can look at
the elections then you can see for
yourself like we live in a very
polarized I mean there's there's no
discussion about everything whether it's
Islam or abortion or gun control a glass
of water like that and one of the things
like well the things that I like because
like it's like it's a dogma and like you
can actually know someone know like
someone position from abortion about
abortion and gun control by ask them one
question right or don't like what do you
think about abortion and then you can
actually know that a position on gun
control because it's like now is like
this polarization of like dogmatism of
the the ten commandments of the left and
the ten commandments of the right and so
I think that both sides have kind of
lost principles of even the
quote-unquote the right I mean they are
supposedly about the free market but
they wanted police people's
vagina and so they they're not as
they're not as free they as they claim
to be I mean they want to please
marriage and they are against marriage
equality there were police
reproductive rights in a Cell and the
left one are supposedly the guys have
free speech wanna have a police so that
is the sad part here if we're jumping
onto the political side of this that the
one guy who wanted smaller government
the one guy who wanted Rand Paul who
wanted you know who's as close to a
libertarian that we're gonna get in the
mainstream parties and I had Gary
Johnson on here a couple weeks ago who's
running under the libertarian ticket
unfortunately luck yeah good luck for
that unfortunately we still don't have a
legitimate a truly legitimate third
party yet but I think that after the
craziness of this year I actually think
it's possible for 2020 but is that the
real fault so we focus on the left but
there was a moment that the right could
have said all right maybe this is the
guy that we should listen to because
he's got some of our principles and then
they kicked him out after I I think one
bad caucus I think it was actually
Islamic extremism what was going on in
the Middle East that really did Rand
Paul's campaign in the rise of Isis and
and you know the havoc that was wrecking
the refugees it's sort of it's sort of
implicated that the United States
couldn't be as isolationist and in the
libertarian position is to just you know
hold back so I think that's what kind of
killed Rand Paul's Rand Paul's campaign
yeah it was interesting because when I
had Gary Johnson on I didn't know what
his policy was on because of libertarian
really you can you don't have to be so
like just like this and so yeah I ruin
everything so when I asked him about
some Italy stuff and some foreign policy
stuff he actually did feel that there is
still a role for the United States but
didn't really lay out exactly what it
was that's kind of really interesting I
mean with the Libertarian Party out of
scenes like yeah I mentioned is this
concept of isolationism which are very
strong in but the thing is like if
you're not interested in the Middle East
that middle east is interested in you
what happens in the Middle East doesn't
it's not Las Vegas like what happens in
Iraq doesn't stay between Vegas in Iraq
but there's one thing that there's
that's that doesn't stay over there yeah
and and that's one thing is Islamic
extremism and I mean because one of the
good things about Islam and I always
admit it's like it is the least lace
bracelets religion and it is
very Universal and it always talks about
universal values I mean one of the
famous quotes of Robert Muhammad in
which he said there's no difference
between Arab and non-arab except by I
think how much faithful is right so
that's so that well that's Universal
except he was saying you have to convert
yes religion transcend borders is that
you can be like the values of Islam can
transcend borders not like a tribal
religion let's say like Judaism is right
like with with Islam so what affects
what's happening in the Middle East can
affect like many people who are
recruiters for Isis are no Middle East
but they are recruiting on the internet
for people living in the West right but
I'm failing to see how you see this as a
positive thing because it isn't that
showing why it's spreading no I mean it
is it's it's a double-edged sword is
that it's a good thing that it's not
racist but it's a bad thing that is
universal you that is a little more bad
yeah isolation of the isolationist
believe that if we can just secure both
the borders if you can ban everybody
from entering or whatever every the
libertarians are kind of gonna get
through it because they believe in open
borders at the same time right reducing
their welfare state so in that way we
can accept more immigrants so yeah how
we're gonna deal with that like with the
Islamic extremism erisa gap with the
refugees coming in with people from the
West getting recruited to join terrorist
groups that may actually make attacks
here in the West like Paris attacks and
Charlie Hebdo and even like now some
like my friend just recently came from
Germany she's a woman from Afghanistan
and she said like in some hotels talent
they they are telling women not to go
out at night out of fear of being
harassed by the newcomers right and
which then ultimately just strengthens
the far-right exactly I tweeted this
morning I saw I saw an article in
Germany that at one of the public pools
where a lot of the migrants are going to
that there were there were a lot of men
that were attacking women and children
so now they're their resolution is that
they're gonna segregate by sex so in a
weird way now the government came in and
did the most sort of the thing that
religion would want the most now we're
gonna separate women and guess what when
people aren't having sex as Bill Maher
would say that sort of fertile ground
for dreamers or extremism yeah and I
mean I think the horse short theory is
like one of the best way to think it's
like not also theories like how much
they feed into each other is that the
more people say that there is no problem
with Islam the more people on the far
right will be getting more powerful
because whatever because there is a
correlation between rise of terrorist
attacks and rise of variety groups
another satellizer for rights groups but
the need for them to get mobilized and
like people like Trump or people like
the EDL English Defence League or Maggie
LuPone in France that when the Paris
attacks happen the moment is like let's
get mobilized let's let's we're losing
our way of life and stuff so I mean this
is one of kind of like the biggest
issues and we were talking about it a
few days ago is that with the rise of
the far-right when they start
quote-unquote killing Muslims or one
attack Muslims and all of that they're
not all that they're attacking people
who look Muslim I mean I I don't have a
right no one's hashtag on my face saying
Muslims but I'm not attacking Muslims
either I mean my parents are Muslims my
grow up with Muslims I love many of them
but I don't want so what's happening is
that when people do not acknowledge the
problem there's these guys are gonna be
and they're gonna be attacking six and
they're gonna be attacking anybody who
looks the brown right so that's the
problem is that they're absolutely are
true racists right there absolutely are
true tickets yeah by the way that's why
I had Tommy Robinson on my show I don't
agree with everything he says and I
don't fully understand everything about
what's going on in the UK and Europe but
I'm trying to learn and I know he had
tried to at least from what I understand
separated himself from some of the more
racist elements of the EDL and some of
those organizations so I thought it was
worthy of a conversation but I think
this is a good segue to something you
said earlier so a certain in Singapore a
certain amount of authoritarianism it
sounds like it made people coexist and
is that sort of on the surface so is
that sort of a it's a very like you got
to thread that needle really carefully
right yeah you know it it it ultimately
it's it's a political philosophy
question and also what is the purpose of
government right it is it to
maintain the most stable society is it
to raise the standard of living of most
people and do the ends ultimately
justify the means because to get there
you know there for example like we in
2007 we've had if you make racist
comments on your blog you can be jailed
so you're not free to make these
comments and how else does that manifest
right so in the United States anybody
can say any racist thing they want
you'll never be thrown into jail for
that yeah anyway you might be booted off
I mean the word racist I mean it could
be perceived as racist then get you in
jail necessarily what we probably all
know what racism is is yeah it could be
something that do you say like oh people
could be something additional blasphemy
laws is essentially you know protect
also the criticism of religion religious
institutions from often very necessary
criticism right it's like you can't even
go there you can't critique and and it
it creates that climate where where
people just don't question because
they're afraid
yeah they don't talk about they just
they're just like safe spaces right now
let's not go talking about let's not go
talking about religion we can't we can
discuss racism very well in Singapore
like it's a very sensitive let's not
talk about it
so people tread on eggshells and and I
mean it's funny because I feel like I
sort of escaped that that scenario like
the you know right sort of a top-down
government instituted curtailing of the
freedom of speech come to the u.s. and
slowly on campuses what starts happening
is now the less asking for the same
thing the students are asking for safe
spaces what you said about the
segregation in Germany right essentially
that's what religion is doing is
creating a safe space between men and
women yeah so like what phase all said
the horseshoe theory it does come
together you know it let the left and
the right extreme left the effectively
are kind of achieving the same results
but also like worth mentioning about
like Singapore even like can you believe
I'm actually from Asia I'm actually on
the same continent
and I think about Asia and I'll try to
keep that in mind judging you for now
yeah is that within I mean eight Eastern
cultures there is a lot of sense of
collectivism yes and there and the
concepts of tribalism that makes it
easier for leaders to tell them like
I've been there in philosophy of
Buddhism and Confucianism
there's always respect to the leader and
like so like it's generally like a
culture itself even China is like yeah
it's less oh so what's happening is that
it's not many people like when they talk
about change in the Middle East and
things of that sort and generally an
Eastern culture you will see that you
don't need to create a critical mass
because you don't need to check Muslim
individuals because it's a collective
culture if you change the leader and the
leader of telling people to look at Iraq
for example within if you look at the
history of Iraq within like last 50
years usually 50 years ago women were by
the free and some places are in Europe
you know and the moment that the
leadership changed they killed some
civil society activists and stuff the
moment everybody starts worshipping and
then and and and so on so like did you
see I'm sorry to drop but did you see
this meme about there was about 30 women
from different countries
you saw this thirty women or fifty women
maybe from different countries at mostly
Arab countries are at least Muslim
majority countries showing what their
what their actual address the indigenous
dress it is supposed to be and it's all
vibrant and they're free their clothes
and it says it's not supposed to be this
and then they show yeah and one of the
things that like live yo G of Wahhabism
and I mean our hobbies and what God used
to be call himself I'm dr. Wahby is
called himself a Muslim reformer that he
wanted to make all the Muslim world
homogeneous and that's part of some of
his success because they're appealing to
this concept that all we all have
different humans and sorry different
cultures and stuff but here am i
bringing all of you under one Caliphate
or under one ideology and all woman need
to wear the same dress in all many and
it's appealing to some people are not
appealing to those who are cultured
right but that's one of the reasons has
been to some extent successful because
it appeals to the people who want to
have the collective mindset who want to
be like part of one umbrella and one
leadership and that's what an Arabic is
called
that's where the word Oh mother Islamic
Ahmad Arabic Amma come from is that
concept of one leadership in one
community and and all of that so the
three of us sitting here three secular
people yeah
atheists right so you grew up Methodist
I didn't even know that until we sat
down just now you grew up Muslim right
that's some extent but yeah but I grew
up in a Muslim culture certainly in a
Muslim culture I grew up Jewish I still
consider myself Jewish but I'm not a
believer in in a magical [ __ ] donkey
I don't believe in the talking donkey or
the fire the talk and the way you know
but it's ideas that brought us all here
and that's why I wanted to have you two
on together because I think that that's
really interesting it shows that these
concepts are a relative transcend
borders and all of that stuff that's
because I really like what really
interested me about sort of joining
forces with Faizal especially right now
with the shift that he's doing with
human rights he's focusing you know not
just on the the atheist movement or the
secular movement well what can we do
about it so he's now working in human
rights and and the reason I'm so
supportive of that and want to be
involved in that is because for me you
know I grew up in a country where I
think one of the the founding father of
Singapore mr. Lee Kuan Yew who recently
passed away one of the most dangerous
legacies he's probably one the greatest
statesman modern statesman you know ever
and he's built a country that went from
third world to first world in just three
decades it's a feat that I mean it's
it's amazing what he's done for the
country but on the other hand he sort of
legitimized this term which kind of
bothers me is he says that it's called
Asian values that because Asia because
of Asia's history and culture the
Western ideas of you know liberal
democracy cannot apply and it doesn't
fit well within the culture and he uses
Confucianism as a bulwark against that
like what he was saying about
collectivism and and so it sort of pits
you know the West Western ideas and it
says oh it's invalid
it can work here and to me that is
cultural relativism you know it violates
human rights like it's it's not it's not
consistent with this right so he's
saying he's saying sort of be free but
not that free because that's sort of
what'll undermine what we feel well well
there are we the legitimize they're able
to legitimize repressive policies under
the guise of Asian values it's almost
like exceptionalism yeah like you know
we we prioritize social harmony and
prosperity over individual freedom so
this is our culture yeah so so our
policies fit that and I think for me
that was what was very dangerous about
that idea and you start seeing it being
replicated in Russia like Putin's doing
that by si Jinping in China and and
they're taking the leaf out of his book
now and and creating almost like
parallel alternative to Western
democracy yeah and part of that again
goes to the way we see Europe having so
many problems right now and we don't see
those problems in Russia right
I mean certainly the the immigration
stuff we don't see that in Russia and
because of that then it makes probably
to the average you're a plane it makes
Putin look kind of good even if they
don't like that Russia is not a country
worth immigrating to somebody who is a
refugee himself wanted to go somewhere
warm yeah not necessarily warm but I
want to have a country that is probably
different than where I come from Italy
Arianism is that I mean Europe I mean
obviously it's much better economically
and much better socially that makes less
people but but yeah I mean I mean when
you have an open border policy that's I
think Germany probably have it and not a
very strong varying system you're gonna
have because as I said there is the rise
of far-right and Islamic terrorist
attacks and if we are not going to
support the Reformers and the Liberals
or trying to change the things in these
societies because I mean I wrote an
article about the Syrian refugee crisis
and one of the main issues is that if
there is no solution to Syria these
refugees gonna keep coming yeah so if
you're not going to find the solution
over there then it this issue is gonna
continue all the time so
and not always serious and obviously
it's Libya is also having a problem it's
Theo Pia and all of other countries in
the region and obviously Iraq since kind
of a long time but the when I don't find
solutions over there so other than just
like focus on domestic issues that's
what like libertarianism fails because
it's always deal when the refugees are
coming here but how can we reduce the
amount of refugees that are coming in
for that page and that's by not
necessarily motor intervention but at
least being on the right side of history
and being with the people who support
the values that reduce them onto faith
right I suspect that most libertarians
would say somebody like Rand Paul would
say well I wasn't for the Iraq war yeah
so I didn't add to the chaos right it's
irrelevant now because here we are now
but I think that is not enough I mean
this concept of like well but I'm not a
racist it's not enough to there's things
yeah yeah and I mean people talk about
the numbers and stuff I mean Saddam
Hussein called hundreds of thousands of
people if the US did not intervene there
will also be hundreds of thousands of
people killed so
so just because saying oh I'm against
the Iraq war does in some money make him
a good person you know what I mean I
mean I'm talking about practical
solutions for I mean the war happened
and we have to deal with it